sido hat Geburtstag der Skandalrapper
wird 29 dazu hat der Mann eigens eine
Single aus seinem Album
ausgekoppelt Geburtstag heißt der Song
und er will sein Leben ändern und
Spießer werden sido in der Online
Talkshow k.de also weißt wirklich diese
spießige ist ja dieses Wort spießig ist
ja immer so negativ behaftet aber jeder
Junge aus dem Viertel aus dem ich komme
hat diesen Traum irgendwann aus diesem
Viertel rauszukommen in einem Häuschen
zu wohnen mit einer Familie und weiß du
immer Urlaub zu fahren wie auch immer
mag spießig klingen WE ist aber finde
ich voll das wünsche ich jedem Menschen
auf der Welt dass er das haben kann dass
er dieses diese Harmonie im Leben haben
kann dass er nicht mehr für 2 50 jemand
abstechen muss vor Jahren habe er diesen
Wunsch noch geleugnet ich habe früher
auch gesagt im Viertel ich bleibbe
irgendw mein Leben lang im Viertel das
Viertel ist das größte und beste was man
haben kann und wie soll ich komme ich
bleib für immer hier auch wenn ich mal
Geld haben sollte das habe ich aber nur
gesagt weil ich keine Perspektive
gesehen habe weil ich nicht den Weg
daraus jemals gesehen hätte und für die
Spießer Zukunft hat er ganz konkrete
Pläne
egal wie Spieß ich das für euch klingen
mag ich will ein Haus am Wasser mit
einem riesengroßen Grundstück
wie hast du das noch nicht nö aber nö
das habe ich noch nicht seit bin ich
auch noch nicht das nee ich bin noch ein
bisschen ich bin zu sehr Stadtmensch
auch ja also noch nicht vollspießer aber
du willst es werden aber das also ich
will dahin ja ich will dahin auch wenn
ich es jetzt schon haben könnte aber ich
wusste ich bin zu jung jetzt dafür ich
so aber da will ich hin ich will eines
Tages nichts mehr machen mus einfach mit
me genzen und mein Leben leben weißt du
und ich weiß nicht wie spießig das ist
so wie wie ja ich find es einfach
nur so legitim ich ich ich möchte das
gerne haben jetzt ist aber erstmal ganz
unspießig auf Tour durch
Deutschland